PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this segment I'm going
to actually show-- well,
you're actually going to show--
the derivative of tangent
x using the quotient rule.
So what I'd like you to
do, I wanted to remind you
of what the quotient rule is.
So u and v are functions of x.
We want to take the
derivative of u divided
by v. I've written
the formula that you
were given in class for this.
And I'm asking for you
to take d/dx of tangent x
using the quotient rule.
And the hint I will give you
is the reason we can obviously
use the quotient rule
is because tangent x is
equal to a quotient
of two functions of x.
It's sine x divided
by cosine of x.
So I'm going to give you
a minute to work this out
for yourself, and then when we
come back I will do it for you.
OK.
So we want to find the
derivative of tangent x.
So let me-- let me work
on this side of the board.
So I'm actually going to
take d/dx of sine x divided
by cosine of x.
OK.
So in this case, sine x is u.
Cosine x is v. So using my
quotient rule I know that first
I have to take the
derivative of sine
x-- that's cosine x--
and then I multiply it
by the denominator, the
v, which is cosine x.
So my first term in the
numerator is cosine squared x.
Again, one cosine x comes
from the derivative of sine x,
one cosine x is the v. It's the
cosine x in the denominator.
Then I have to
subtract v prime u.
The derivative of cosine
x is negative sine x.
I'll actually just
write that one down.
And then I bring the
u along for the ride.
So I multiply by sine x here.
And then I take v squared in the
denominator from the formula.
v, again, is cosine
x, so I take cosine
squared x in the denominator.
Now this at this point
is a little bit messy,
but the nice thing
is that we can
use some trigonometric
identities to simplify this.
So let me first write out what
it is a little more clearly.
Minus a negative
gives you a positive.
And then here I get
sine x times sine
x, so I get the sine squared x.
And then I keep divided
by cosine squared x.
Now at this point
some of you might
have divided by
cosine squared x here
and gotten 1, and divided
by cosine squared x here
and gotten tangent squared x.
And then from there
you could simplify
to another
trigonometric function.
I'm going to go straight a
different way to show you
what that actually also equals.
So there, at this
point I want to stress
there are sort of two ways
you can get to the same place.
But I'm going to use the
fact that the numerator is
a very nice trigonometric
identity that we know.
We know cosine squared x plus
sine squared x always equals 1.
So this is quite lovely, the
numerator simplifies to 1,
the denominator stays
cosine squared x.
What is this function?
1 over cosine x is
actually secant x.
So if you need, at this point,
to rewrite the whole thing
like this, right?
1 squared is 1 and in
the denominator we still
get cosine squared x-- this
tells you that 1 over cosine
squared x is actually just
equal to secant squared x.
So again, what I
want to point out
is we've now taken the
derivative of tangent x
and we got that that's
secant squared x.
Now using this
quotient rule, you
can do the same kind of
thing with cotangent x,
with cosecant x, with secant x.
You can find all
these derivatives
of these trigonometric functions
using the quotient rule.
So if you want to know what
the derivative of secant x is,
you should take d(dx of 1
divided by cosine x and use
the quotient rule.
Or, in fact, the chain rule
would work well there also,
to find that derivative.
So we are building up
the number of derivatives
we can find using
these different rules.
So we'll stop there.